donc c'est une profession aujourd'hui
qui est très très impactées par le par
là par la hausse des deux centimes
forcément
c'est une profession qui impactait pas
que d'aujourd'hui
malheureusement
effectivement ça représente environ
200 à 300 euros par mois
dans notre chiffre d'affaires est
rapportée alan et ses environs entre
2500 et 3000 3500 euros tout dépend
évidemment des des chauffeurs et du coût
du kilomètre qui roule
forcément ça a un impact
sur notre vie quotidienne
chose qu'il faut savoir c'est que nous
notre taxi mais notre rôle d'atr ça fait
deux ans qu'il n'a pas été remis à jour
c'est à dire que généralement tous les
ans on a et non on a une mise à jour qui
nous permet de rattraper cette hausse du
coût de la vie alors évidemment c'est
très minime puisque ça assez de l'ordre
un sentiment général du kilomètre ça
fait deux ans que
bacon a pas eu de mise à jour et nous
faut savoir que le prix du compteur à la
fin bah là le client va payer le prix du
compteur
on va pas on n'a pas la possibilité
comme certaines professions de
répercuter dans dans
voilà les prix sont fixés
concrètement je pense que le
gouvernement s'est totalement planté sur
ce coup
comme sur d'autres malheureusement mais
je crois que il aurait dû retirer tout
de suite ces deux centimes répondre à la
demande du goût des français je pense
qu'ils n'en seraient
vraiment sortis grandis surtout à un an
des élections il aurait dû tout de suite
répondre et enlevé ses deux centimes
je crois qu'aujourd'hui les français
avec cette histoire de chèques
qu'ils n'attendent pas un chèque tu peux
dire aujourd'hui ils demandent des
mesures concrètes et immédiates
on parle du chèque on nous dit que ça
sera pour certains au mois de décembre
pour certains au mois de janvier
il y en a qui ceux qui gagnent moins de
2000 euros ça sera bon ceux qui gagnent
de 1000 euros ceux qui gagnent plus de
2000 euros et non pas le rush et je
comprends pas il croit que moi je pense
que tout le monde a droit à sec dès lors
vous rouler avec une voiture et je vois
bien ce qu'ils vont venir et qui vont me
dire oui mais le riche ceci venant le
reste si le reste là le riche celui ci
les risques peut-être qui sait donner
les moyens et s'ils roulent avec un gros
suv ou un porsche cayenne et il a autant
besoin que le pauvre qui roule peut-être
le pauvre notant que des chèques d'un
montant différent selon les rues
c'est vraiment la poudre aux yeux moi je
crois que s'ils n'annoncent totalement
bancale si une annonce totalement
bancale et aider malheureusement des cas
les valeurs
qui est très mauvaise pour le
gouvernement malheureusement et je pense
qu'il aurait dû retirer cette histoire
de thé